[Music]
zootopia aka zootropolis hit theaters in
2016 and beat just about every record
there was to break at the time even
today the movie is still one of the most
popular disney films rightly so we
believe zootopia has succeeded in
becoming a film that is truly for
everyone with an exciting story and
enough grown up humor there has been
speculation for a long time whether and
when the second part will be released
however things have gone quiet on this
topic so we want to look back on it for
you we've dealt with the subject of how
realistic zootopia 2 is and most
importantly what this story could look
like before we get into that let's recap
part 1 around judy hobbs and nicholas
byberry's nick wilde thus for those who
have not seen it you might want to skip
ahead quickly or even better access your
disney plus subscription and watch the
movie now
judy hopps is a bunny with great
ambitions as she dreams of becoming a
policewoman and so after graduating from
high school she sets off on her journey
from bonny borough to zootopia where she
joins utopia's police department quickly
she realizes that she is not accepted as
a woman cop by the others as a superior
meter mate she has to fight her way up
the hierarchy when she mets nick the fox
the latter tricks her causing her only
to become angrier on the verge of
quitting mrs otterton seeks her help her
husband is missing and although chief
bogo is not pleased judy has her first
case along with nick she sets out to
find mr otterton and it soon becomes
clear that there is more behind it they
discover that many animals are missing
all of them predators and most
importantly that they have gone berserk
or rather extremely aggressive during
their investigations they find out that
mayor leo the lionheart has had the
animals trapped and imprisoned but
merely to find out what is wrong with
them as he claims nonetheless he has to
vacate his post and the second mayor
dawn bellwether the sheep assumes the
position on his behalf now the ambiance
turns towards the predators in town and
the animals have to deal with fear
however julian nick find out that
bellwether is to blame for everything as
she holds a grudge against the
carnivores and does intend to get rid of
them together they manage to foil her
plan and nick ends up joining the zpd
himself
unfortunately we don't know anything
about the exact plot yet but there are
some rumors floating around about the
second part of zootopia and also the
online community has some ideas besides
it can be said that the social topics
addressed and the first part alone can
be further expanded in an interview with
cinema blend nick's voice actor jason
bateman already revealed that the two of
them will tidy up the streets as
partners there are some new cops out
there he added so bad guys be warned
thus it is evident who will be in the
thick of the action once again judy and
mick
but not only as official partners at the
zpd as there seems to be something else
going on between the two of them after
all the first part ends with nick
claiming that judy knows she has a crush
on him which she confirms so pretty much
everyone agrees that there will be some
kind of love story developing around the
two of them who knows this might even be
something special in zootopia so far we
know that only animals of the same breed
have ever become a couple and here we
are actually talking about two hostile
species nowadays this would of course
strike a chord again if the movie
addressed topics such as free love and
different sexualities in general they
could take up the topic of gender one
more time and explore in more depth judy
is the only bunny working for the police
and besides officer francine the
elephant she's also the only female who
seems to be working for the authorities
in general most of the animals we
encounter are male besides her and
francine we only see the star singer
gazelle the concerned mrs otterton and
mafia heiress frufu and don bellwether
this could be a neat transition to
sexism in society
we also hope that the two partners will
finally make it to the areas of zootopia
that haven't been shown yet although
we're told at the beginning of the film
that zootopia is a huge city we only get
to see downtown rainforest district and
tundratown in the course of the first
movie yet there are many more urban
areas to explore like the camel district
canyonland marshlands meadowlands polo
strait and sahara square however the
capital city is not the one that should
be of interest for the upcoming
storyline we actually do not know
anything yet about the planet or the
continent in which the movie takes place
sure there were a couple of scenes in
bunny burb but that's it there's still
an entire world to discover besides so
far only mammals have been featured in
part one what about other species like
fish reptiles and insects in case these
creatures really exist the second film
could deal with the question of why they
were excluded from zootopia and
re-examine the topic of xenophobia
a somewhat sensitive topic could be that
of class society at first glance
everything in zootopia seems to look
like love peace and harmony yet just by
looking at nick and his accomplice at
the beginning of the film it seems that
there are animals who have to earn their
money in a shady way in the city of
endless opportunities and so there's for
instance also a mafia in zootopia a
story about this would be particularly
suitable for nick in his old life after
all until he met judy he was not really
doing any honest work you say the gap
between rich and poor might be too
severe for an animated film well then
don't forget one of the core messages of
the first film in an amusing way it
shows how racism is a fear that is
promoted by those in power therefore the
next part could well try its luck with
other serious topics
what most of you probably do not know is
that zootopia was originally intended to
be a spy movie where a spy arrives on a
mysterious island in a world full of
mammals perhaps it could be a storyline
for the sequel and why not it's not cast
in stone that nick and judy have to stay
with the zpd forever especially nick
could be well pictured in the role of
his secret agent the second part could
easily revert from buddy cop comedy to
the originally envisioned spy genre
so now we've heard a few possibilities
of how the plot could go on but what
does the fan community on reddit
actually say there one theory has
prevailed namely that we will meet
nick's father in the course of the film
and that the latter will be arrested by
judy when the interrogation reveals who
it is nick falls back into his old
behavior patterns the rest of the movie
will then delve into nick and his
father's past and find answers as to why
he abandoned him before he was even born
in general fans on reddit are crying out
to know more about this live fox
but when is zootopia 2 coming opinions
differ on this because disney has not
even officially confirmed the second
part some years ago they probably would
not have even thought of making a sequel
but since wreck-it ralph and frozen they
are considering a theatrical sequel
looking at the numbers this would only
be natural as zootopia was one of the
most successful movies from the disney
animation studios in the last 10 years
here it is worth noting that december
21st 2022 is a day that will see the
release of a disney animated film about
which nothing else has been announced
yet anyways it is safe to say that
zootopia 2 will not be hitting theaters
before the end of 2022 as soon as we
know more you will of course be notified
in our weekly news
well here we go those were all the
theories about the second part of
zootopia which idea do you think is the
best so far and do you have any other
suggestions on how it could continue let
us know in the comments if you enjoyed
this video feel free to give us a thumbs
up and if you don't want to miss any
more of our videos you might want to
subscribe to us see you next time bye
[Music]
you